There's no doubt that it's really easy to
just criticize without offering an alternative.
And it's also much easier to see things in
retrospect than inadvance.
Now on Twitter, more and more people, some
in good faith, have been saying to me, some
are trolls, some are acting in good faith.
You know, David, you're doing a lot of criticism,
but what should Donald Trump have done differently
to better deal with the pandemic?
So that's what I want to talk about now.
Now, if you want to just say any hindsight
analysis is worthless.
Well, OK, then you can click off and go somewhere
else now.
But we actually do have some very specific
things to talk about here.
So there's the big picture.
And then there's the micro.
First of all, before we even deal with the
specifics now as a general thing, Donald Trump
never should have disbanded the pandemic response
team and he never should have cut funding
to the CDC.
This is what they are supposed to work on
all the time.
We don't know when the next pandemic will
hit.
And Trump said back when he cut the pandemic
response team said we don't need to be paying
for people that aren't really needed, that
aren't really doing anything right now.
We now know why they were needed.
That pandemic response team never should have
been eliminated.
Now, let's get to the specifics of the here
and now.
Back in December when this started, we now
know that inside the government, they were
already discussing it immediately.
At that point, you say if X happens, we banned
travel.
If Y happens, we do this.
You have parameters for when will you start
shutting down travel?
Based on what takes place instead.
Trump didn't do that.
We were persistently behind the curve.
And despite the fact that he's bragging about
how early he did these things, that's not
true.
OK.
You also back in December right away, you
then figure out how many masks do we have,
how many ventilators do we have, how would
we distribute them?
You probably start distributing them in early
January to be ahead of the game by mid-January.
There were already hundreds of cases.
That's when you start getting the masks and
ventilators to hospitals instead of what's
happening now, which is we don't know where
they are.
They're not telling us the truth.
The president of mass general here in Massachusetts
is asking people to start 3D printing masks
at home and Trump and Pence daily just sort
of stumble around about we're mobilizing this
resource.
We are bringing this online.
We are requesting production.
Everything happened four to five weeks late.
Early January, you immediately ask private
industry, which Trump loves.
He loves private industry.
He always talks about it.
You immediately go to private industry and
you say develop a rapid test now and also
develop an antibody test.
We are not using an antibody test here in
the United States.
This is important to figure out who has already
had it.
So many people now believe they had mild cases
of this.
Imagine if we could know that just hypothetically,
five percent of the population has already
had this and has recovered mild or asymptomatic
cases.
It's really important to know that we don't
have an antibody test.
You could have months ago pushed private industry
to develop that now.
And also you immediately say let's start testing
treatments now.
So instead of now wondering would chloroquine
and as this is it, throw mice and work?
Is it safe?
What about AV again?
What about REM desert vier?
You start doing that in late January, early
February, Trump said to Anthony Foushee over
the weekend.
Wouldn't you have liked to have had two more
months on this?
You could have had them.
We are eight to 10 weeks behind on just about
all of this stuff at this point in time.
Also, by late January, you've got to shut
down the China flights.
Trump didn't do it until February.
You can also I you absolutely.
Trump's clueless and appointing pense late
is idiocy.
In January, you bring on a covered czar.
I would suggest Ronald Clayne.
This was Obama's Ebola czar.
Would we look him up on Twitter?
That would've been a great person to appoint.
And realistically, you do the Europe flight
bans in February instead of March 12th. Trump
didn't do it until March 12th.
Very, very late.
By the end of February, you need a.
Tional stay at home.
Order.
It may be coming eventually, we don't know.
Every day lost is a tragedy here in Massachusetts.
We got not a shelter in place, but guidelines
about no school take out only at restaurants,
etc.
We got that on March 15th, starting the 17th.
Every day you lose.
We see how it affects the curves.
And Trump doing that at the end of February
would have really prevented a lot of what
we're now dealing with.
Also, you have to negotiate the economic side,
right?
The deal.
Every day they say we're figuring out how
to get money to people.
We're figuring out how to bail out industry.
We're figuring out how to bail out small business.
They're still arguing about the specifics
and nothing has happened yet.
Who knows when anybody might get money now?
You have to get that going in advance and
have it ready being ahead of the game.
But we have a system of government.
We have a moronic person at the top and we
have an economic system, quite frankly, that
doesn't work in this way.
It's reactive instead of proactive.
It's gotten very, very ugly.
Let me know what you think.
I'm on Twitter at David Pakman.
I also want to tell you, because we're all
hopefully staying at home.
We've rescheduled The David Pakman Show Viewer
Chess Tournament.
It's this Wednesday night, March 25th at 8:00
p.m. Eastern.
Okay.
There will be information about how to play
on social media.
Anybody can play regardless of your skill
level.
The tournament will be on chess, dawg.
That's allied chess dot org.
All you have to do is get an account on Lee
chest dot org.
I invite you participate in the David Pakman
Show Chess Tournament this Wednesday evening,
March 25th at 8:00 p.m..